foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Thursday January 19th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
nearly a decade ago 3D printers were
being touted as the future home
appliance that would revolutionize the
world we'd all be printing the things we
needed Star Trek replicator Style
it led to a boom in investment in 3D
printing companies and a lot of flashy
stories but that hype has mostly faded
how much demand is there for printing
your own chocolate bar
but in place of the hype a funny thing
is happening that technology is
beginning to quietly revolutionize some
Industries and could have implications
for the shape of Global Supply chains
joining me to discuss how and why this
is happening is our Tech columnist
Christopher Mims hi Christopher thanks
for coming back on the show Hey Zoe
always a pleasure to be here
so for those of us who may have
forgotten can you give us a quick
refresher on how 3D printing Works 3D
printing builds up an object one layer
at a time so it's almost like growing an
object whereas traditional manufacturing
you cast it or you extrude it or you put
it into a mold or something like that
give us some examples and why are these
different from the ones we saw maybe
five or six years ago what's happening
now is that 3D printing is starting to
become a mass manufacturing process
whereas in the past it either could not
make parts that were strong enough to be
used in devices that people would
actually use in their homes or in a
factory
or it was just too expensive so part of
this is that there are new stronger
Plastics that are being used for 3D
printing but also there's all these new
types of metal 3D printing and the
results are for example 3D printed
stainless steel parts that meet the
exact same specification as a cast
stainless steel part and so as a result
they can go into machines in one example
that I found in my research was a
company called curio in Iceland and they
make fish processing machines which is
kind of a big deal because normally when
you pull fish out of the ocean in one
place you got to ship it halfway across
the world to where the labor is cheaper
typically in Asia to you know gut and
fillet and skin the fish but if you have
one of these machines which is made with
parts which are 3D printed in this
little facility in Iceland you can keep
that labor local so he was an early
adopter because in the old days and this
is true of many manufacturers in the
west if you wanted a metal part made you
know you had to drop all the
specifications send those to somewhere
in Asia somebody would make it for you
they would send it back you would test
it maybe it's not perfect you wait a
couple more weeks for that cycle to
repeat and it's just not very cost
effective or efficient but if you can 3D
print a part test it doesn't work
immediately tweak it and that part that
you've created is the one that you're
going to use in your machine because
maybe you're only producing a few
hundred of these machines per year as
opposed to tens of thousands
then it totally makes sense in that
context are these companies mostly
smaller manufacturing outfits or are
they bigger companies as well
some big companies are getting into this
so GE has started 3D printing parts for
itself BMW is using 3D printing
throughout their supply chain HP has
started making industrial 3D printers
for others so just the printers not to
mention the software and the materials
are a multi-billion dollar market all
over the world already but it's still
nascent right like you can't compare it
to the number of
metal objects that are cast every year
using conventional means but it is
growing very quickly and some of the
analysts I talked to said you know
because of supply chain pressures and
people wanting to reshore manufacturing
this could grow very quickly in the next
five to ten years much more quickly than
it has in the past five to ten years and
you said we're just at the early days
but are there drawbacks that even now
some companies are having to deal with
when it comes to 3D printing the biggest
drawback is cost so if you want to go
above you know a few tens of thousands
of units
it just makes more sense to manufacture
the old way it'll be faster kind of per
item that you're creating and it will
cost you less money I mean these days
industrial 3D printers they're large but
it can still take you know 18 hours to
print you know a large metal part and
the only reason that it's cost effective
at all is sometimes you can print many
parts at the same time inside a single
volume that's being printed or you have
many 3D printers running in parallel so
the technology really does need to scale
up like it needs to become 10 times
faster so yeah 10 times cheaper Etc if
it's gonna eat more of the manufacturing
Market are there certain products that 3
3D printing is just better at making
than others I mean we heard early on
that 3D printing was going to make us
chocolate bars and cars and clothing
that just the list went on and on so are
there certain things now that they're
realizing actually 3D printing is good
for this and not so good for that we are
definitely not about to get the Star
Trek replicator you know I remember
decades ago I wrote about 3D printed
Pizza that they were gonna launch on the
space station or something that kind of
stuff doesn't make sense there's certain
materials you also just can't really 3D
print you can't 3D print a window let's
say you can't 3D print the body panel of
a car because there are just other ways
to do that that are so much better so it
is going to find limited application
it's definitely not going to be
everywhere
it does make a big difference though for
certain types of plastics Metals things
that we rely on for our everyday life I
mean a million technology up and all
sorts of
enormous that 3D printing was going to
be that and yet it's still to many
extents hasn't been so is this the
moment that that changes is 3D printing
kind of coming of age right now
I think for some parts for some
applications
3D printing is finally finding practical
widespread application you know there
was a ton of hype early on it's starting
to live up to some of that promise but
you know as with all Technologies it
takes longer and it's not quite as
revolutionary as we're initially
promised so for small manufacturers this
works but should people who work in
manufacturing be worried about their
jobs being taken over by 3D printing in
the U.S at least the challenge we really
have is that there just aren't enough
people
in manufacturing there are not enough
people learning kind of the older way
you know Machining and casting and other
ways of doing things but one company I
talked to that makes parts for the
automotive industry said this has
actually helped them with hiring because
young people who are used to you know
doing everything on a computer they come
in and they go straight from a 3D CAD
model to you know on the factory floor
right next to them this thing gets
printed out they don't even have to get
their hands dirty it's more intuitive
and it feels like the future to young
people who otherwise might not be
excited about going into manufacturing
so the future may be soon upon us that's
our Tech columnist Christopher Mims
thanks for joining us Christopher thanks
for having me Zoe and that's it for
today's Tech news briefing for more Tech
stories head over to our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
foreign